cette semaine l inde et portante pour un
des sujets sur lequel je travaille en
tant que vice présidente de la
commission du commerce international
c'est le blocage de l'organe d'appel des
règlements des différends au sein de
l'om c'est pourquoi il ya un blocage
en fait c'est donald trump qui a refusé
le renouvellement de juges au sein de
cet organe d'appel est derrière ce refus
en fait nous sommes arrivés à une
paralysie de l'organe de règlement des
différends symbolise et ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est les raisons du
refus de donald trump derrière qui se
cherche à faire c'est semer le désordre
économique mondiale
[Musique]
quand tu en l'organisation mondiale du
commerce que nous arriverons à relever
les défis donc deux parlements européens
s'engagent pour défendre le
multilatéralisme préserver l'unité
européenne
et pour faire en sorte que ce ne soit
pas le far west et que véritablement on
est un commerce plus juste et plus
équilibré
[Musique]